Public Defenders the only people who
appear in court more frequently than
former child stars even if you have
never come into contact with the public
defender you will know them from their
important cameo in the Miranda warning
speech you have the right to remain
silent you have the right to an attorney
give the right to an attorney give the
right to an attorney you have the right
to an attorney you have the right to an
attorney yes apparently even Garfield
knows he has the right to a public
defender and he's going to need one too
because he just murdered a lasagna and a
person the right to a lawyer is a pillar
of American jurisprudence but it's a
right that we've only had since 1963
when the Supreme Court unanimously ruled
that any person who is too poor to hire
a lawyer cannot be assured a fair trial
unless a lawyer is provided for him it's
an idea so obvious you can't believe
there was ever a time that we didn't
have it like corn on the cob holders
that are shaped like corn on the cobs no
one should ever have had to come up with
those they're essential to the fabric of
American life the problem is our public
defender system is currently massively
overburdened depending on the
jurisdiction anywhere from 60 to 90
percent of criminal defendants need a
publicly funded attorney and the system
is creaking under that weight right now
there are about 20 public defenders
handling up to 250 cases in New Orleans
for example each public defender handles
roughly 350 cases a year
public defenders in Fresno County often
work on a thousand cases a year when
state guidelines say they shouldn't be
doing more than a hundred and fifty
thousand cases in a year that's nearly
three cases per day those are Gerard
Depardieu wine consumption numbers
at breakfast and and with caseloads that
heavy public defenders cannot possibly
prepare an effective defense a study New
Orleans a few years back found that the
city had some part-time defenders who
could only spend an average of seven
minutes per case and that is not long
enough to prepare anything
if I only had seven minutes to prepare
this show I definitely would not be
talking about public defenders right now
I'd be desperately trying to fill time
by listing the Muppets in order of
ability I'll do it now Fozzie first
obviously obviously you go fuzzy first
most attractive thing is a sense of
humor don't you gotta go Ralph
you've got to go role then you know what
I'm going Swedish chef and I'm finishing
up with Sam the Eagle because you know
he's into some freaky business this is
just the beginning of the problems some
places don't even have a public
defender's office and and some counties
just contract cases out in bulk to the
lowest bidder and at its worst this can
result in a system known as meetin and
pleadin where the vast majority of
defendants plead out and never even go
to trial 90 to 95 percent of all
criminal cases state and federal are
resolved by plea bargaining now just
think about that about 95 percent of
criminal cases never make it to trial if
law and order reflected reality their
episodes would be pretty short it
basically just be how does your client
plead guilty your honor and then this
[Music]
and as a viewer you would justifiably
feel cheated by that and look it is easy
not to care about this it's easy to
assume that if someone is being
represented by a public defender
they're probably guilty but many are not
and some only please because they feel
they have no alternative look at her
face Stewart
she was arrested in a drug sweep but
claimed she was innocent she faced a
10-year sentence and was stuck in jail
because she couldn't afford bail
she said her court-appointed lawyer
urged her to take a plea deal and she
will ultimately agreed please will fire
your probation you know just just let me
go home to my kid she admitted to a
crime she denies committing just to
spend time with her children that is
horrifying especially because I would be
willing to commit a crime just to not
have to spend time with any children
they are loud cesspools of bacteria with
nothing interesting to say oh you want
to grow up and be a princess I'll tell
you what happens to princesses actually
google diana + truth do it doo doo Biltz
google it actually now after omer pled
guilty the prosecution's case collapsed
and the other defendants who didn't take
a plea deal had their charges dropped
but oma could not take her plea back so
she had to spend five years on probation
during which she was ineligible for some
form of public assistance and wound up
homeless and that is the problem with a
system that can a lot as little as seven
minutes to helping people make decisions
that can affect you for the rest of your
life our public defender system is
dangerously under-resourced one report
found out that 40% of all county based
public defenders have no investigators
on staff that's 40 percent of lawyers
forced to sit at their desks googling
where to get exonerating evidence and
hitting on feeling lucky
and the offices those desks are in could
potentially lack basic standards of
workplace health and safety tough to do
your job when you're competing with
countless roaches crawling around your
office but that is the work environment
and ordered by employees at Augustus
public defender's office and it's so bad
that the office had to close early today
and this infestation is nothing new
oh it's been going on for four years
that office is getting to a point where
roaches are outnumbering than lawyers
and unless one of those roaches happens
to have a law degree from the University
of Rochester and can help take on some
clients that's going to be a problem as
for New Orleans their public defender's
office has actually put up a
crowdfunding page to help make up their
budget shortfall and it's currently only
raised 19 percent of its goal and look
nobody should be in jail because a
Kickstarter didn't meet its goal if
anything some people should be in jail
because a Kickstarter did reach its goal
like this one for an actual giant
inflatable Lionel Richie head YouTube
gentleman should be locked up all night
long all night all night but despite all
these enormous challenges there are
still some amazing lawyers like Travis
Williams he frames every acquittal and
puts it on his wall but guess where he
puts his losses I'm gonna get the last
name of every case I've lost tattooed on
my back right now it's only five and
hopefully it won't get hopefully I want
to feel my back though that's to go but
since the lot since Elena's going to
wall I decided the losses have to go
somewhere they're going my back but they
don't give me felt he tattoos the names
of the cases he's lost on his back that
is a truly heroic lawyer he's like
Atticus Finch only real and not as it
turns out a horrible racist
screw you Fucci Gulf come knockin Birds
the point is many public defenders do
heroic work despite facing overwhelming
institutional obstacles including this
incredible incident involving a Florida
judge not pissing me off
just sit down I'll take care of I don't
need your help right to be here if you
want to fight let's go out back and I'll
just look around
that is clearly a disgrace although I
will say folks like that would make jury
duty a lot more interesting Your Honor
we have reached a verdict we find the
proceedings to be fling awesome
incidentally that judge returned to the
courtroom and called seven cases without
the public defender being present and
he's still on the bench and look a bad
judge can come and go as the head of
programming at NBC will tell you but
access to a lawyer is supposed to be a
constitutional right and it is
increasingly under threat
for instance in four states you can make
so little that you qualify for food
stamps but still not be poor enough to
get state-funded representation and in
at least 43 states you can be billed for
a public defender meaning in these
states we have a system where
conceivably you if you cannot afford an
attorney one will be provided for you
provided that you pay that attorney
which is absurd you can't tell people
something's free and then charge them
for it this is the American judicial
system not candy crush and and for what
this can look like on a human level meet
Larry Thompson in 2010 he was arrested
in Florida for driving with a revoked
license which was a felony charge
because he'd had multiple driving
violations before Larry was sent to jail
where he applied for a public defender
which in Florida incredibly requires a
fifty dollar application fee he couldn't
afford to pay that or his bail so he was
stuck in jail for 59 days at which point
he gave up and pled no contest to get
out and was released on time served but
in Florida if you use a public defender
and have found guilty even by plea you
then Oh attorneys fees and costs
regardless of your ability to pay so
Larry now old not just the $50 public
defender application fee but also an
extra $100 fee for having used the
public defender and even another fee of
$100 to pay the prosecution's costs
which is like taking like a bully taking
your lunch money and then charging you
an additional lunch money reallocation
fee but they still weren't done on top
of those and other fees for the cry
pled no contest to the court then added
partial payment fees each month for the
next several months
bringing Larry's tab to six hundred and
seventy five dollars and that all brings
us to about a month ago when Larry was
actually arrested for contempt of court
as a result of not paying those fees and
arrests incidentally for which they
charged him a two hundred and ten dollar
administrative fee at this point they
may they may as well have just slapped
on an irony fee for good measure because
it turns out having no money in Florida
can be really expensive or one
more thing when they arrested Larry he
was receiving hospice care for a
terminal pulmonary condition and was so
ill that gel was forced to send him to
the hospital where he was watched by two
guards and chained by his ankles to his
hospital bed luckily he was eventually
released and his debt was paid by donors
who heard his story but he still
understandably could not quite believe
what had just happened to him I never
knew they would actually arrest the
person in my condition well not being
able to claim money because I have a
favorite so I can't see them I keep
arresting the old man over to take me
back to jail it charge me 250 more
dollars that I have to agree to I guess
I'm sitting in jail when I can't get
oxygen in jail like I needed so they dig
me actually an issue in me a distance
none of things makes any sense
it doesn't even make fiscal sense
because the state of Florida did collect
the eight hundred eighty five dollars in
fines that Larry owed them but in doing
that they spent thousands of dollars
needlessly imprisoning him and surely
Florida could have used that money for
something they badly needs like I don't
know rehab programs for meth-addicted
swamp raccoons
I'm assuming accurately but but the
point is 50 years after the Supreme
Court gave everyone the fundamental
right to an attorney even if you can't
afford one we now have a system where
the most vulnerable people are
potentially being charged for access to
a hideously broken system and we either
need to fix that or at the very least
update the Miranda warning in our cop
shows to reflect reality
you have the right to remain silent the
right to remain silent you have the
right to remain silent anything you say
can and will be used against you in a
court of law
you're the light you're an attorney
you're gonna afford an attorney one will
be provided for you I did it alright
we're not done I'm not done I'm not
finished that attorney may have 300
other cases that he or she is working on
that's not a joke literally 300 other
cases potentially have a total of seven
minutes to prepare your defense do i
short seven minutes is no short seven
minutes it Billy Joel's scenes from an
Italian restaurant is 37 seconds longer
and that attorney that attorney that
attorney may be exhausted unable to
think straight the attorney is likely to
be grossly underpaid or working in an
office crawling with cockroaches you
know what really blows that attorney may
pressure you to take a guilty plea
statistically statistically
statistically there's a 90 plus percent
chance that you will take that guilty
plea an attorney may get challenged to a
fight in the hallway by a judge that
guess where I don't know yes
come on guess Florida of course it was
Florida how could it not be fun one more
thing that attorney that is provided for
you may not be free if you lose you may
have to pay them you might even have to
pay the prosecutor is that
constitutional its constitutional as
you piece of
and all this assumes that we can even
pay for that lawyer how's the
Kickstarter campaign doing now do you
understand your rights as I have
explained them to you know what no
basically
you